euh on va passer à notre invité du soir
que vous attendez tous il est 20h57 on
est en direct nous aussi sachez-le on
attend ça sans déconner on est j'ai
l'impression que je suis à deux doigts
je suis à 5 minutes de mon fils qui va
casser la la pièce montée pour sa Bar
dir je suis comme un
fou on va recevoir Jérémy Assous
l'avocat dianx on rappelle cette
histoire de film Gérard de pardieux qui
était en Corée et il y a eu ce
complément d'enquête derrière qui a é
commenté par tout le monde même par le
Président de la République donc voilà
donc pub énorme pour complément
d'enquête bien entendu mais coup de buzz
ou coup de bluff et apparemment Jérémi
Assous l'avocat Max a énormément
travaillé et il semblerait pour eux que
ce sera un coup de bluf et il semblerait
qu'il ait des preuves du trafic des
images je dis bien il semblerait il va
nous on va faire le dérouler devant vous
ce soir en direct on va lui dire même
nous on va lui dire ce qu'on en pense
est-ce qu'on pense que
c'est voilà est-ce que c'est c'est
recevable ou est-ce qu'on trouve que
c'est léger je vais vous dire vous allez
voir Jérémy qui est extrêmement
persuasif va nous dérouler tout le truc
avec les images à
l'appui et Jérémy Assous vous dis c'est
pas n'importe qui c'est l'avocat qui a
fait trembler la téléréalité d'ailleurs
je vous le dis moi j'étais j'étais
j'étais en procès pendant des années
avec lui ou et aujourd'hui je lui dois
de l'OSS non je rigole non non non je
rigole non non non pas du tout non non
il très bon jéréi Assous et c'est vrai
qu'il ne lâche rien tout le monde
l'appelle d'ailleurs en ce moment Jérémy
Assous tout le monde l'appelle alors
sachez-le aussi petite info que va nous
donner Jéré assassous sachez que France
Télévision France 5 l'avait invité c'est
à vous il lui avait dit si tu vas chez
adouna tu viendras pas chez nous ça veut
dire que c'est à VOUS ils sont prêts à
taper maintenant sur leurs propre
collègues de France 2 pour vous dire
c'est les gars ici y a personne qui a te
face bien sûr ils ont pas de face les
gars ils ont les leurs collèges de
France ils veulent les défoncer vas-y
bah tu sais quoi B non ça peut faire de
l'audience ma rappelle jéréy Assous sais
quoi et ben il va nous il va nous foncer
complément d'enquête en direct sur enfin
pas en direct SS sont pas en direct ils
auraient monté sur Fran 5 donc voilà les
génies qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je
vous dise et ça nous nous jamais on
l'aurait fait je vous dis ça jamais je
non mais c'est c'est extraordinaire ça
ça confirme ce que tu dis regardez on va
revoir bien sûr la fameuse vidéo qui
aurait été trafiquer voilà et c'est à
VOUS bah ils ont qu'à nous regarder ils
vont voir ce qu'aurait dit Jérémy Assous
chez eux voilà demain ils le diffuseront
chez eux voilà comme ça ils seront
contents ça leur coûtera moins cher leur
coûtera au moins un taxi au moins alors
regardez son adorable VO adore faire du
cheval elles ont le le clitau qui frotte
sur le ha de le pomau de la seelle et là
ça ah mais vous c'est c'est des c'est
des grosse
il va même jusqu'à sexualiser une
fillette d'une dizaine d'années si
jamais il galope elle
jouit c'est bien ma fifille continue tu
vois elle se gratte là non une éducation
il est 21h on est en direct merci Maître
Jérémy Assous d'être avec nous et je le
dis Jérémy Assous dans le milieu de
l'audiovisuel
c'est un déponte voilà je le dis et je
dis pas ça parce que tu es avec nous ce
soir vous êtes avec nous ce soir maître
Assous VO je vous le dis on va revenir
point par point sur ce que vous avez dit
je vais vous suivre en fait parce que je
dois lancer des images donc vous détenez
des éléments qui contredisent totalement
le constat de Luissier venu chez France
Télévision alors c'est mieux que ça
ah c'est plus simple vous savez quand
vous voulez mettre un terme une
polémique quand vous voulez
convaincre je vais pas me servir de mes
pièces parce que on pourra toujours dire
ah il faut qu'on ait le temps de les
vérifier il faut qu'on puisse les
analyser ù ça se trouve ces pièces sont
infondées si vous voulez vraiment gagner
c'est comme au judo vous vous servez de
la force deadversaire et donc des pièces
deadversaire là je me sers et je ne
m'appuie que sur les pièces de France
Télévision à savoir leurs images qui ont
été diffusées et leurs constat puisque
personne n'a vu le constat
excepté leur partenairire
France Info il y a que France Info qui a
publié des extraits de ce constat
d'accord et donc il est très important
et on va y aller point par point puisque
en effet ce qui a provoqué la chute de
l'ogre puisque c'était le but puisque
c'est le titre quand même de ce sujet
donc la chute de Gérard de pardieu c'est
pas les blagues à répétition de mauvais
goût soit ça Lass pour certaines qu'on
lui a demandé de faire en tant que
personnage dans le film l' métage C
cinématographique de yanx puisquon a les
contrats de fiction c'est le fait et je
reprends la voix off de complément
d'enquête le fait qu'il ait sexualisé un
enfant ex et en effet le fait d'avoir
sexualisé un enfant vous glace oui et si
on considère que c'est vraiment le
Gérard pardieu dans l'intimité dans la
vie réelle bah c'est quelque chose qui
vraiment disqualifie socialement et donc
vous avez la première image alors on va
revenir dans son procès verbal donc
Luissier constate que tous les propos
contestés ont bien été tenus dans le ara
à ce moment-là et surtout il l'indique
c'est ce qui dit Luissier mais Luissier
Luissier il regarde les images va
regarder il va dire bah c'est cyil c'est
pas un expert Luissier c'est c'est un
huissier c'est bien ce que ça veut dire
Bernard Montiel était huissier voilà
donc il constaté voilà et comme ici il
vient dans l'émission il constate au
cours de cette séquence donc je constate
qu'à l'exception de la jeune fille seul
des cavaliers d'apparence masculine
entrent en premier plan des caméras
voilà alors ça c'est très important oui
l'traitier publié par France Info et en
effet on se dit à lire cela que à
l'exception de la jeune fille donc de
l'enfant il n'y a que des hommes et
l'image d'après ça vient sur une voie
off Gérard de par Dieu sexualise
l'enfant et vous avez l'image sur
laquelle on voit cette petite entourée
de trois hommes un cavalier et deux
moniteurs derrière où il est écrit si on
peut voir l'image à l'antenne si jamais
il galopee elle jouit oui donc là bien
évidemment avec ce que annonce Luissier
on se dit tous bah il l'a dit oui bien
sûr sauf que faut lire d'un peu plus
près ce que dit Luissier et c'est pour
ça que votre régie a eu raison de
souligner luisser dit en premier
plan parce que je rappelle quand même
que Luissier c'est un officier
ministériel il peut ne pas tout dire
attention il peut mentir par omission
mais il ne peut pas mentir sinon là
c'est automatiquement une condation il
perd son titre d'accord et ça ça a
attiré notre attention pourquoi parce
que en premier plan ça veut dire qu'il y
a peut-être un second plan c'est ça et
ça c'est il constate les images qu'on
lui a donné et il constate et il dit moi
en premier plan je le vois que des
enfants un enfant et tris hommes est-ce
qu'il y a un second plan et c'est
intéressant alors on se pose la question
on recherche est-ce qui fait l'analyse
du second plan s'il le précise c'est
qu'il y a un second plan plan et là
c'est très curieux parce que il ne dit
rien mais il y a autre chose c'est que
Luissier ne constate pas cette fameuse
phrase si jamais il galopee elle jouit
alors que le monde qui est aussi un
grand soutien de complément d'enquête
ainsi que France Info partenaire de
complément d'enquête indique que les
images qui eux ils ont vu du film de
Part Dieu dit oh c'est bien madame si
jamais elle galope elle jouit et
attention dit Madame oh c'est bien
madame si jamais elle galope elle jouit
et complément d'enquête qui a comme
partenaur France Info donne encore plus
d'information à leur partenair et ces
derniers écrivent oui en effet il dit ça
il dit même oh c'est bien madame si
jamais elle galope elle jouit s'il l'
fait galoper elle mouille elle jouit et
là on se dit mais comme l'a dit le monde
il parle de cette
petite Yan MOX a toujours soutenu que
Gérard de pardieu n'a jamais à aucun
moment de la séquence parler et
sexualiser cette petite alors Monsieur
max vous êtes bien aimable mais moi j'ai
un constat de Guier qui me dit qu'il y a
que des hommes à part une petite fille
et j'ai Gard de par que
j'entends si jamais il galope elle jouit
de qui parle-t-il il parle d'une autre
cavalière elle est où cette autre
cavalière elle est au second plan et
voilà est-ce que on peut avoir le second
plan exa si vous prenez image par image
vous avez est-ce qu'il y a une femme
dans le Hara et là vous avez une
cavalière ah bah oui qui je vous
rappelle et ça c'est très important à la
différence et vous pouvez faire image
par image ou alors le regarder chez vous
puisque c'est encore en ligne à mon avis
ça sera plus longtemps c'est la
cavalière à la différence et on le voit
avec la queue du cheval à la différence
de la petite qui est sur un poney et
ouais n'est pas au pas mais au trop
comme chacun sait notamment de par Dieu
qui est quand même fin connaisseur en
matière d'équitation qui a quand même
joué à trè nombre de films où il était
cavalier en matière d'équitation il y a
plusieurs vitesses nous avons le pas
nous avons le trop et à la suite du trop
le Galot et donc quand de par Dieu dit
oh c'est bien madame madame c'est une
dame bien sûr si jamais elle galope donc
puisqu'elle est au trop si elle passe à
la vitesse supérieure elle jouit ça
c'était ce que lui avait demandé MOX de
es le B qui commment des cavalières
voilà et voilà elle passe donc si jamais
son moniteur l'a fait passer au Galot
c'est la deuxème phrase s'il l'a fait
galoper
elle mouille elle jouit et ce qui est
extraordinaire que je termine juste une
chose Monsieur si jamais il galopee elle
jouit c'est la phrase qu'on voit sur
l'écran de complément d'enquête
figurez-vous que cette phrase n'est pas
dans le constathissier pourquoi elle est
pas dans le constathissier par rapport à
l'image qui correspond à la petite
entourée de trois hommes parce que de
Part Dieu ne la prononce pas en
regardant la petite il la prononce en
regardant la cavalière qui est une
adulte donc c'est la raison pour
laquelle il y a ce fameux plan de coupe
il y a ce sous-titre et a la voix off
avant est-ce qu'on peut revoir l'image
pourtant parce que les journalistes de
complément d'enquête pour il n'y avait
pas de doute d'ailleurs ils ont resserré
l'image petite fille j'aimais qu'on voit
les mat parce que eux ils font ce qu'on
vient de voir là ils viennent ils
resserrent en fait ils resserrent sur la
volontairement pour qu'on se
diseçone façon ils se sont dit ils
verront jamais rien ils vont pas revenir
là-dessus ils vont pas faire une enquête
là-dessus et il savent pas que ça allait
faire un boss comme ça il l'espéit tout
même puisque ils l'ont quand même mis en
teaser pour annoncer le complément
d'enquête mais il n'y a pas que ça il y
a pas que ça vousz les téléspectateurs
disent déjà c'est fou comment on peut
trafiquer c'est pour ça qu'on accorde
une confiance extrêmement importante à
aux producteurs de télévision et au
télédiffuseurs et que en cas de
manquement même non intentionnel ils
sont sévèrement sanctionné mais en cas
de manquement intentionnel ils sont
gravement sanctionnés qui plus est sur
le service public mais là ce n'est pas
c'est pas le tout c'est que puisqu'on a
des extraits bien sûr de Luissier allons
allons allons tout lire là j'ai plus de
Madame ils ont fait disparaître le
madame puisque sinon tout le monde
aurait eu le même réflexe que nous
pourquoi il parl de Madame enev le
madame c'est si Madame si oh c'est bien
madame si jamais elle galope elle joue
il y a plus de Madame c'est grave ça il
ge ont suprimé la prre il est sousenttin
qui
s'adress mais vous n'avez pas vous
n'avez pas que cela vous n'avez pas que
cela c'est supprimer le madame ça c'est
sûr à partir du moment où vous avez un
premier plan de caméra et on voit qu'il
y a un deuxième plan de
caméra on va regarder vraiment le
deuxième plan de caméra et là ce qui est
extraordinaire c'est que c huissier qui
vraiment évite les obstacles puisqu'il
sait que son constat va être exploité
par France Télévision et va être public
je rappelle quand même que comme par
extraordinaire personne n'a le nom de
cet huissier personne n'a le constat
personne n'a le nom de cet huissier je
rappelle que les huissiers c'est un peu
comme les avocats ils sont rarement en
manque de publicité he s'ils peuvent et
je sais de quoi je parle s'ils peuvent
faire état un peu de leur nom parce que
ça ramène ça fait ça génère une certaine
notoriété là comme par hasard luisser le
plus discret de France j'espère que
toutes ces images vont être reprises par
les autres médias bien sûr mais mais
bien évidemment mais de toute façon si
c'est pas reprise par les autres médias
en tout cas ça sera reprise par le
procureur de la République voilà bravo
ce qui est très important c'est que cet
huissier travaillons avec lui cet
huissier nous nous indique que il y a à
minima deux caméras et lui il constate
deux caméras professionneles avec des
time codes donc on peut comparer bien
sûr il refuse de les images et de donner
accès aux bandes pourquoi puisque la
bande d'audio avec la bande image on
pourra voir si elle matche si elle ne
matche pas il y a bel et bien montage et
donc trucage en espèce vous avez la
deuxième difficulté quand même dans ce
complément d'enquête en ce qui concerne
la position de Dian max il a jamais
sexualisé la petite fille écoutez c'est
un peu gênant monsieur parce que il y a
quand même un constaticiier qui dit on
voit la jeune fille sur un équidé guidé
par un homme après après cette séquence
juste quelques secondes après
ù monsieur de par Dieu ça c'est
l'huissier qui je lis le constat
d'hissier monsieur de pardu dit c'est
bien ma fille fille continue tu vois
elle se gratte là Monsieur Dedieu dis
c'est bien et là j'ai souvenir que Julie
de pardieu très naturellement avec une
immense sincérité
dit mais vous savez mon père appelle
Fifi tout le monde pe appeler Fifi une
vieille dame une jeune dame une femme
c'est ridicule mais quelle défense et
cetera et inconsciemment nous aussi on
se dit Fifi c'est plus pour un enfant
qu'une adulte d'autant que quand on
regarde cette
séquence on ne voit que le moniteur et
la petite quand il dit tu vois elle se
gratte première observation moi
personnellement je vois pas personne se
gratte mais surtout je me dis même si
ils ont manipulé monté le si elle galope
si jamais elle galope joui il reste là
alors la question c'est est-ce qu'il
parle de la petite est-ce qu'il parle de
l'enfant il y a moi assuré que non et je
suis convaincu qu'il a raison pourquoi
parce que voyez-vous toujours sur
l'hissier qui se fait un plaisir de nous
dire je vois caméra
1 ce que le l'équipe de tournage filme
et caméra 2 elle filme d'autres un autre
angle bah voyez-vous quand je vous ai lu
le constat d' Luissier donc la
retranscription tu vois elle se gratte
c'est la caméra 2 et luissimet entre
guillemets sur la caméra 2 on voit la
petite fille sur équidé guidée par un
homme trois petits points je sais pas ce
qu'il y a entre les trois petits points
monsieur de pardieu dit c'est bien ma
Fifi continue tu vois elle se gratte là
trois petits
points
soit est-ce que je peux avoir l'analyse
de la caméra une parce que là c'est la
de si se gratte et là je l'ai pas ouais
ah ouais voir si gr si grat
là imaginons une seconde que gérrard de
pardieu parlait toujours de la même
cavalière puisque c'était une espèce de
blague à répétition on en pense qu'on
veut mais ça arrive c'est qu'on peut
demander à chaque fois qu'elle passe
puisquelle est au trop elle passe bien
plus vite que la petite ouais chaque
fois qu'elle passe tu fais une
remarque c'est peut-être sur la caméra 2
et ben regardez de près l'image quand
vous regardez image par image en ce qui
concerne la petite on peut avoir la
conviction et donc la preuve que il ne
parlait pas de la petite mais il parlait
toujours de la même cavalière celle qui
a 35 ans pourquoi parce que si vous
continuez là vous avez le commentaire de
Gérard de Padieu mais voilà si jamais
elle se
grat voilà si jamais il galope elle
jouit au continue au continue donc là on
il dit la phrase c'est bien ma fille
fille continue donc pour nous tous il
parle d'elle bien sûr tu vois elle se
gratte là et là regardez continuez
doucement les images les images là c'est
la caméra 2 mais regardez on peut de
voir ce que filme la caméra une juste
après c'est juste était dans la
continuité de ce que vous avez vu je
peux vous le montrer ici c'est pas une
difficulté continuez continuez vous
allez voir que se présente stop stop un
joli cheval à côté oui et ce cheval bah
voyez-vous il a une particularité c'est
il a le haut de la tête du cran
il est bien blanc et en bas on voit au
niveau de la gueule il a un peu comme si
il était beaucoup plus noir et ben ce
cheval il y en a qu'un dans le
Hara et il est monté par qui à votre
avis regardez on peut en faire une
comparaison puisquon a également des
images et vous avez une qualité d'image
qui est bien meilleure que celle sur mes
ordinateurs où on voit la jeune femme et
c'est exactement la même tête et donc
ils ont vol irement mis des propos
Gérard de pardu sur la petite à un
moment où elle passait bien év bien
évidemment devant lui et il se servait
de la fameuse caméra à plan serré où on
ne voyait que la petite et les trois
autres et le cavalier alors que derrière
vous aviez cette femme qui elle avançait
au trop et pouvait passer du Galot à
tout moment et c'est à propos de cette
femme et aucunement à propos de cette
petite cette enfant donc en est en effet
Yan Max a toujours dit la vérité
lorsqu'il a soutenu que il n'avait
jamais été témoin de la moindre remarque
ambigu même ambigu de Gérard pardu à
propos d'un enfant et que en aucun cas à
ce moment-là dans ce Hara Gérard de
pardieu a sexualisé un enfant et ça
c'est très important parce que c'est sur
la base de ces
images sur la base de ses propos que
Gérard de pardieu a véritablement euh
chuté pour reprendre leur expression et
a été même lynché et tout le monde a
perdu la raison puisque bien on comprend
on peut comprendre que dès qu'on parle
de des enfants et un adulte qui
sexualise sérieusement un enfant dans
ces caslà on considère qu'il n'a pas à
faire partie de notre communé et c'est
une exclusion sociale et c'est
véritablement scandaleux et il y a moi
je voudrais dire rajouter un truc en
plus ils l'ont balancé avant sur les
réseaux sociaux bien sûr c'est un boss
énorme c'est ça c'està dire que les gens
ont parl av C BIM avec le même succès
mais certains bouim c'est un peu ce que
vous faites merci oui c'est vrai ave pas
avec le même succès merci en tout cas
maîre Assous ça été incroyable on avait
l'impression d'être dans F et vraiment
on ne pensait pas avoir autant de
preuves parce que là les preuves je
trouve qu'elles sont irréfutables je ne
sais pas quelle va être la réponse de
complément d'enquête ni de France
Télévision mais là franchement pour moi
c'est rideau on va en pararler demain
bien entendu dans cette émission parce
qu'on va revenir sur tout ça est-ce que
vous avez un dernier truc à ajouter j'ai
j'ai quelque chose de très simple là
pour l'instant ce n'est qu'une analyse
plus ou moins précise exhaustive nous
avons fait mieux de leur pièce après
nous avons les nôtres et puis après vous
allez quand même avoir celle de la
police puisque il va y avoir une enquête
puisque là vous pensez bien qu'il y a
des actions judiciaires qui sont lancées
contre complément d'enquête enfin France
Télévision et le producteur Antony
Dufour et les réalisateurs de ce sujet
de complément d'enquête mais une fois de
plus je comprends beaucoup mieux
pourquoi ils ont toujours refusé de
communiquer ité du CAT pourquoi ils ont
toujours refusé de communiquer les Roch
et même à la police pourquoi et qu'il
nous disent pas oh secret des sources
bien évidemment le secret des sources
faut le respecter il est extrêmement
important il y a c'est pas une source là
c'est un sujet et qui fait polémique
dans lequel il y a des véritables
accusations qui sont portées contre
Gérard de par Dieu et on démontre que ce
n'est pas le cas et on peut pas opposer
le secret des sources à l'arcom et donc
j'invite tout à chacun puisque nous
allons le faire à saisir
l'arcom demander que ils imposent à
France Télévision et àifilm de se
justifier et donner des explications et
j'invite également le gouvernement
notamment le ministre tutelle de France
Télévision à le faire puisque une fois
une fois de plus c'est un sujet qui me
tient vraiment à cœur parce que j'ai un
peu travaillé sur ce qu'on appelle les
fake news donc la diffusion de fausses
nouvelles
si on peut laisser cela sans sanction et
si vous ne faites pas la làdessus ça
décrédibilise tout le service public
audiovisuel
l'investigation merci j merci merci
merci d'avoir été avec nous vous avez
été incroyable je me suis régalé c'est
mon émission préférée je merci tout de
suite West sur merci à
tous